arriving officers encountered the mail
outside the residence
the mill produced a long gun an exchange
of gunfire ensued breaking here at four
Henderson police reporting no injuries
in an officer-involved shooting a luxury
home that caught fire shortly after the
incident thank you for joining us here
at four I'm Kirsten Joyce and I'm
Christian God said as Henderson Police
say they were called to the home just
before noon in the area of College Drive
and Paradise Hills Madison Kimbrough
joins us live now after a briefing from
police Madison
yes it's a very active scene here as
Henderson Police has been out here for
hours as of now and this started as a
family disturbance of a suicidal male
making threats the caller stated that he
would fight officers and have officers
shoot him arriving police encountered
the person outside of the home with a
gun there was an exchange of gunfire
police then repositioned themselves and
then there was another exchange of
gunfire followed that the mail
eventually surrendered but during this
incident the house caught on fire now
it's still unclear if that man is the
one that set the house on fire but we
spoke to a neighbor Robert hunt who goes
for his daily bike rides to Boulder City
and today he said he saw a huge Blaze
very thick smoke and very big see a lot
of response a lot more response and I
think for a regular fire it's kind of
odd
trained and taken into custody and in
the end there were no reported injuries
but two officers were involved in the
gunfire exchange now we still don't know
what led up to this incident it's
unclear if the person that made the call
was a family member as far as a child
but we do know that it was a male person
within the home so we are working to get
those details for you of course keep it
here on 8 news now for the latest
details reporting live in Henderson
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now